hey this is david 2 i'm a network
specialist at google cloud
welcome back to what's new in networking
today we'll guide you through our new
load balancing and service networking
launches
first are new features around external
and internal load balancers
next we'll take a quick stop discussing
traffic director
and we'll finish off our journey with
private service connect stay
tuned
[Music]
first stop is our external network load
balancer the network load balancer is a
regional pass-through load balancer that
distributes
tcp and udp traffic among virtual
machines in the same region
as you might know the network load
balancer leverages target pools
or target instances with the recent
launch we've enabled the use of regional
backend services
similar to target pools a backend
service defines how cloud load balancing
distributes traffic
but now back in service configurations
give you fine grain control
over how your load bouncers behave it
contains a set of values like protocols
distributions and settings health checks
and timeouts
so what does this launch mean first this
launch gives feature parity for the same
backend services
as other google cloud load balancers
like our global load balancer
or our tcp and ssl proxy load balancer
second it transitions from legacy health
checks to unified health checks
which allows you to configure tcp health
checks third
it enables connection draining and
lastly it enables failover groups
alright now let's move on to what's new
with the internal network load balancer
prior to this launch if you are ever
required to send traffic to a single
internal load balancer virtual ip you
are limited to only one forwarding rule
per virtual ip address with this launch
you'll now be able to configure multiple
forwarding rules with the same virtual
ip
now you'll have the flexibility to
define different protocols such as tcp
or udp to the same virtual ip
in addition you'll have the flexibility
to have multiple forwarding rules
to the same virtual ip but exposing
different
ports this launch gives you the ability
to have various flooring rules
combinations
pointing to the same virtual ip now that
we've covered our load bouncers
let's cover two new additions to traffic
directory
our fully managed traffic control plane
for service mesh
introducing tcp services support for
traffic director
this feature enables you to use traffic
director to route traffic to services
that expect
non-http traffic such as databases or
voice over ip services
those of you who have tcp based services
get
global load balancing for multi-region
services such as cross
regional failover and overflow a fully
managed control plane for tcp traffic a
consistent control plane across
l4 and l7 traffic and you can easily
connect workloads to external services
for those of you that use proxy list
grpc with traffic director
and need additional visibility now you
can with
observability for proxies grpc you're
able to access
monitoring and tracing metrics that help
you solve configuration and networking
issues with your deployment
best of all you can export these metrics
to cloud monitoring
and cloud trace you can then build
dashboards and charts
and even use them as a basis for
automating alerts
our last feature is private service
connect for google apis
prior to this launch there were two ways
of connecting to google apis
the first is over the public internet
this requires your client to have a
public ip
or go through nat to hit a public api
endpoint
the second was to configure private
google access private google access
removed the requirement to have a public
ip
or go through nat now your clients can
privately route traffic to private
endpoint ips that google defines
with the launch of psc for google apis
you have the ability
to create multiple custom endpoints of
your choosing
now you get more control over which apis
hit
which endpoint and it remains completely
private to your vpc
and that's what's new in networking for
load balancing and service networking
thanks for sticking around till the end
i welcome you to start using these
features
and be sure to take a look at the links
below for guides on how to use them
stay tuned for the next what's new in
networking